public sénat et éco dds vaud présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu qu'ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui il est question de notre
pouvoir d'achat et c'est une quasi
certitude il devrait baisser cette année
avec le grand retour de l'inflation
alors faut-il se résoudre à ce qu'ils
soient durablement affaibli on posera la
question est l'économiste patrick artus
vous verrez également qu'il existe des
plateformes pour aider les ménages à
sortir la tête de l'eau enfin ya des
solutions pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux salariés c'est ce que nous
dira bertrand dumazy le pdg d'edenred
mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur l'évolution de notre pouvoir d'achat
en moins d'une minute c'est parti le
pouvoir d'achat c'est quoi ce sont tous
les biens et services qu'un revenu
permet d'acheter
comment le calcul ton on regarde d'abord
le revenu disponible
c'est à dire les revenus d'activité les
salaires ou les pensions par exemple
augmenter d éventuelles prestations
sociales et diminué des impôts puis
l'évolution des prix calculé par l'insee
sous la forme d'un indice l'indicé des
prix à la consommation
si la hausse des revenus est supérieure
à celle des prix le pouvoir d'achat
augmente dans le cas contraire ils
diminuent et l'inflation dans tout ça en
mars la hausse des prix a atteint un
niveau record plus 4,5 pour cent sur un
an la faute aux prix de l'énergie qui
ont augmenté de 29 % des produits
pétroliers ont augmenté de plus de 40 3%
puis aux transports avec + 6,1 pour cent
l'habillement +3 5% ou encore
l'alimentaire plus 2,9 pour cent donc
notre pouvoir d'achat baisse eh bien non
entre 2017 et 2021 il a augmenté de 0,9
pour cent par an soit en moyenne 300
euros de plus chaque année dans le
porte-monnaie pourtant 80% des ménages
estiment que leur pouvoir d'achat a
reculé ces dernières années l'année 2022
devrait leur donner raison avec le grand
retour de l'inflation
[Musique]
avec une inflation proche de 5% notre
pouvoir d'achat devrait connaître cette
année un choc historique vaujour patrick
bonjour d'avs et patrick artus chef
économiste de natixis a que 5 %
d'inflation c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas
connue depuis coin 40 ans oui peut-être
pas 40 or les palois oui au début on a
connu ça dans les années 80 et puis très
transitoirement
à certains moments sortie de la sortie
de récession dans le passé n'oubliez pas
que si l'état français n'avait pas pris
à sa charge une partie très importante
de l'os des prénoms sera la première à
beaucoup plus façon serait pas à ça
qu'on serait à sept ou huit les
allemands sont à s'être l'europe et à
cet ennemi donc en fait moralement on
est à sept rondes et a5 simplement parce
que l'état a pris une partie de la
facture énergétique donc la contraction
notre point d'achat cette année sera
très important et je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir au delà de 2,7 à des cirques
il faut se dire alors cette année oui
les salaires vont augmenter de 3 %
probablement d'après toutes les
informations que nous avons des
différentes branches or une inflation à
5 donc on aura deux points de baisse du
pouvoir d'achat d'ailleurs on voit que
pour l'instant seul le pouvoir d'achat
des plus modestes pour l'instant résiste
parce qu'il ya encore des effets des
chèques énergie déchets l'inflation
il faut quand même se placer dans une
perspective un peu plus longue pour
comprendre ce phénomène on retrouve un
monde où il ya des raretés on avait
oublié qu'ils avaient des raretés 1
aujourd'hui on a rareté de l'est de
l'énergie rareté des métaux rareté de
certaines matières premières agricoles
rareté du transport rareté des semi
conducteurs dont le dans un monde où il
ya plein de rareté les prix montent et
on a oublié les mécanismes d'indexation
des salaires qu'on avait il ya 30 ou 40
ans donc on a ce mélange rareté est
faible indexation des salaires
mécaniquement fabrique le recul du
pouvoir d'achat et je crois qu'il va
falloir apprendre à vivre parce que
c'est rare t on les voit pas disparaître
de sitôt c'est quoi c'est une très forte
demande croissante de biens
l'électronique l'équipement de la maison
et ça c'est une conséquence de la
coville la russie c'est pas demain que
les sanctions sur la russie sont levés
et puis après la transition énergétique
qui va faire consommer beaucoup de
métaux qui va qui avait de la tension
sur les marchés de l'énergie donc on va
devoir apprendre à vivre durablement
avec avec d'inflation beaucoup plus
forte que que dans la décennie 2010
alors ça ça pose plusieurs questions la
première c qui prend la facture et là il
ya une question centrale qui est d'abord
un combien de temps l'état peut
continuer à amortir le choc à partir du
moment où l'état ne peut plus assurer
cette charge comment cette charge
répartie entre les salariés et les
entreprises et ça c'est crucialement la
question de l'indexation des salaires
dans les années 80 les salaires étaient
très bien avec ses sur les prix et donc
les salariés étaient protégés et la
facture été prises par les entreprises
et on a eu un effondrement des profits
d'ailleurs dans les années 80 et est en
conséquence de l'investissement est
aujourd'hui pour l'instant les salaires
sont très malades etc c'est donc les
profits surprenant que déjà le sujet il
est là il faut augmenter les salaires
peut-être pas tous en tout cas les bas
salaires si l'état accepté de pinces et
des marges des entreprises alors c'est
globalement globalement en bonne santé
oui mais c'est un débat assez profond
elle et essayer de serre vrai c'est
vraiment le vrai débat de politique
économique qu'on devrait avoir et qu'on
n'a pas eue c'est de dire si on a un
horizon de temps assez court on a envie
de protéger la consommation des ménages
donc on va privilégier une bonne
indexation des salaires sur les prix et
sur nos horizons dans l'eau on a envie
de protéger la croissance de long terme
donc de protéger l'investissement et ce
moment là on a plutôt envie de protéger
les marges donc c'est un vrai choix même
de prédire de société et à savoir si on
protège les salariés ou surprotège lait
les marges des entreprises qu'il faut
expliqué patrick artus et que autant en
2022 notre point d'achat va en moyenne
reculé autant depuis cinq ans oui
chiffres à l'appui linsellois wsop thème
les vôtres en moyenne le faire d'achats
a progressé pourtant les français sont
convaincus du contraire est ce que le
terme et riz n'est pas cassé écoutez
ville aux clients je crois pas j'ai
vraiment travaillé cette question il ya
le travail de l'eau est cela qui qui qui
qui vient d'être publiée qui extrêmement
intéressant qui montre que depuis cinq
ans jusqu'au début de cette année
puisque la de ces mois ci c'est bizarre
mais depuis c'est encore le pouvoir
d'achat de tous les français quel que
soit le niveau de revenu a progressé
d'autant plus que leur revenu est faible
donc non seulement à une progression du
pouvoir d'achat mais il ya eu leur
élégance et leur écrasante majorité le
contraire après les français en
attendant les enquêtes 80 % des français
disent qu'il ya un recul de leur pouvoir
d'achat alors l'explication usuels c'est
les fameuses dépenses contraintes ce en
disant oui
mais lille a beau nier
internet
l'énergie est bien sûr l'alimentation ce
n'est pas vrai non plus même si on
corrige des dépenses contraintes il ya
toujours une progression du pouvoir
d'achat des français même un petit peu
plus forte alors que si la différence
assez sur une perception c'est une c'est
une perception c'est sans doute que la
perception de ce qui est une
consommation indispensable quand on a du
mal à boucler les fins de mois on a du
mal oui mais parce que oui mais parce
que c'est mon explication c'est que ce
qui est perçu comme étant indispensables
comme consommation est de plus en plus
large aujourd'hui personne n'imagine
plus de parloirs d'abonnement à des
plates formes de cinéma
il ya dix ans personne n'imaginait que
ça faisait partie de la consommation à
distance une dépense contrainte c'est à
dire en gros un certain moment
pratiquement tout devient une dépense
contrainte alors si tout est une dépense
contrainte évidemment il ya des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et il faut
l'accepter cirque il faut que les
politiques acceptent l'idée que quels
que soient les chiffres de l'insee qui
disent linverse les français ont la
perception que leur pouvoir d'achat
s'est réduit ce n'est pas vrai mais ils
ont cette perception donc on ne peut pas
faire comme si cette perception
n'existait pas et donc il va falloir
trouver des politiques de pouvoir
d'achat alors même qu a priori il n'y a
pas de problème qu'en tant que c'est une
situation qui est extrêmement complexe
et c'est une spécificité française à
vous avez pas ça du tout dans les autres
pays européens et donc comment trouves
comment on trouve une solution pour
faire changer cet état d'esprit des
français ça alors là les solutions elles
sont sur la table oro il faut s'attaquer
aux plus bas salaires donc augmenter bas
salaires augmentent et les plus bas
salaires mais ça va très vite à vous
savez on dit en général que les français
se sentent un peu à l'aise à partir de
2000 euros net par mois mais il ya 65 %
des français qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros d'être par boire donc ton combat
et est en ce moment en particulier le
smic augmente extrêmement vite puisque
lui il est indexé sur les prix mais pas
le reste des padres et donc on est en
train de casser encore plus d'ailleurs
archi des salaires au bas de l'échelle
des salaires dont deux solutions
d'abord le smic et rappelez-vous que le
smic est indexé par sur l'indicé général
des prix mais sur un indice des prix
particulier aux français à revenus
modestes et puis deuxième solution ce
que propose beaucoup de patrons le medef
c'est
arrivé le dividende salarial c'est
génial et rigolote ben si c'est très
simple c'est une entreprise qui ne verse
pas d' intéressement une participation
n'a pas le droit de verser des
dividendes à ses actionnaires donc c'est
simple c'est si vous voulez verser des
dividendes aux actionnaires vous devez
intéressez vous avez vos salariés aux
résultats de l'entreprise c'est une idée
que le medef maintenant signe donc c'est
quand même assez intéressant de voir
cette évolution et puis voilà il donc il
faut faire des petites choses comme ça
mais si on perd on n'est pas en position
c'est pas les états unis on peut pas
augmenter tous les salaires de 10% parce
que ça n'a aucune justification
macroéconomiques ont deux on
effondrerait les marges bénéficiaires
des entreprises sachant que les vraies
inégalités patrick elles sont peut-être
même plus patrimoniale nous ignorons dit
pas assez on a des chiffres dire là
dessus oui on a des chiffres parce que
maintenant on publie alors au d'abord on
sait que les inégalités de revenus en
france c'est con à mesure par la
vieillesse de gym où les inégalités sont
nettement plus basse que dans les autres
pays européens dans les autres affaires
aux disparitions sera-ce la distribution
est à vendre distribution on est très
inégalitaire c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
ça j'aurais dû le dire avant une des
raisons d' une des explications c'est
que l'on est dans une situation où ce
sont les politiques redistributives qui
aboutissait des inégalités faible est-ce
que de l'argent reçu de l'état la prime
d'activité par exemple c'est perçu comme
de la même manière qu'un salaire c'est
pas tout à fait certain que c'est à la
même perception qu'un salaire d'un
garçon qui est versée par l'état donc
voila et puis de temps qu'il faut
effectivement trouvé des boyard aussi de
réduire les inégalités patrimoniales
alors qu' elle augmente considérablement
parce que les prix des actifs augmente
considérablement et que les plus on est
aisé plus on investit dans des actifs
financiers qui ont des rentabilités
élevées donc ça conduit à ce que les
salariés soient actionnaires de leur
entreprise alors il faudra c'est alors
une des propositions c'est une
augmentation extrêmement forte de 2 des
distributions d'actions gratuites s'agit
pas de faire acheter des actions aux
salariés même avec un bonus un comme
c'est très fréquemment le cas j'ai donné
une partie du capital de l'entreprise
pour le reste y vend à ses salariés
aujourd'hui le cac 40 à 3 et demi pour
cent de son capital qui est propriété
des salariés des entreprises pourrait
dire président de la république pourrait
dire au terme du quinquennat ce sera 10
% pareil donc on aura enrichi
patrimoniale mans les salariés dans leur
entreprise il faut retrouver des
initiatives aussi pour le polar les
inégalités patrimoniales un petit mot
comme des chèques énergie qui ont été
distribués par les pouvoirs publics est
pour moi une question ciblage on a donné
100 euros à 38 millions de français ce
qu'il fallait pas donner 400 euros à 9
millions de français oui et on aurait pu
parler aussi du de la remise de 18 cents
à la pompe oui c'est fini en bénéficier
à la fois comment dire aux hauts-sarts
et modeste qui prennent leur voiture
pour aller au boulot comme le cadre
supérieur qui prend soin suivait pour
partir en week-end à la campagne les 18
centimes d'essence ses bénéficiaires
tout le monde donc l'arbre de
déperdition d'argent public que
conseillera donc il faut pas faire ça et
en plus on fait disparaître le signal
prix ont fait semblant que l'énergie
fossile et pas cher que ce qui était
aberrant donc il faut laisser monter le
prix des énergies fossiles et il faut
faire des chèques aux plus modestes ça
coûtera beaucoup moins cher à l'état et
sa puce sera tout le monde à faire des
économies avec une inflation fini à ce
qui est structurellement plus élevée
dans les prochaines années notre point
d'achat sera sous pression quand les
taux d'intérêt les taux d'intérêt vont
continuer à monter on est ravis recul 4
% pour le taux d'intérêt à 10 ans à la
fin de cette année on sera peut-être à
2% la fin de l'année prochaine on sera
peut-être à 3% un certain moment l'état
de pour a pu suivre et donc il devra
laisser les salariés les entreprises
s'expliquer entre eux et c'est là qu'on
aura à la
répartition pour l'instant ce mode de
répartition a été entièrement cachées
par les interventions de l'état merci
beaucoup aux explications signé patrick
artus donc chef économiste de natixis
merci patrick mercier et pour ceux qui
ont du mal à boucler les fins de mois à
cause justement de l'inflation l'api
give peut être une vraie respiration
manuel d'aigre la préoccupation des
français pour leur pouvoir d'achat
atteint des sommets
pour l'augmenter il n'ya que deux
solutions accroître ses revenus ou
baissé ses charges et dépenses et c'est
sur ce dernier point que les français
ont tendance à se tourner
abordons sur les bords de la garonne
nous avons rendez vous avec béatrice
depuis quelques mois elle est inscrite
sur une application qui lui permet de
faire des économies
alors ça s'appelle div c'est une
application qui permet de donner de
recevoir des objets en tous genres salah
et vêtements de la nourriture des
meubles entre particuliers comme
béatrice ils sont trois millions et demi
d'inscrits sur l'application et se
transmettent des objets et de la
nourriture sans jamais mettre la main à
la poche d'ailleurs il y a quelques
jours béatrice a posté une annonce donc
la moye jénine à lens par exemple pour
des colliers pour les chats béatrice ne
l'aimé plus à ces animaux de compagnie
alors au lieu de les ranger ou pire de
les jeter elle préfère leur offrir une
seconde vie et faire faire des économies
à une autre propriétaires de chats la
vie a considérablement augmenté et donc
c'est se donner un coup de pousse les
uns les autres et j'ai rendez vous dans
quelques minutes avec raphaël raphaël
est la première à avoir répondu à
l'annonce les deux femmes se sont donné
rendez vous dans le centre de bordeaux
donc voilà les trois petits colliers il
y a quelques mois béatrice les a acheté
8 euros pièce ils sont super
vois tu vaux mais en un an raphaël
aurait économisé environ 1000 euros
c'est bien parce que j'ai des petits
revenus pour le moment et c'est un grand
soulagement et grâce à cette application
je me sens hyper riches ça me permet de
payer mon loyer plus sereinement ça me
permet de d'être plus tranquilles
évidemment way depuis 2010 est la
plateforme connaît un véritable succès
et a permis de réaliser 15 millions de
dons entre particuliers
et selon l'un de ses créateurs
l'application n'a jamais vu un rôle
aussi important qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre société
give aujourd'hui est devenu un
instrument extrêmement important
effectivement pour pour gagner un petit
peu en pouvoir d'achat pour arrondir les
fins de mois sur le principe de
il n'y a pas moins cher que gratuit
parce que chez nous tout est gratuit
l'application se rémunère principalement
grâce à la publicité
on a vraiment toutes les catégories de
population toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles ça va de
l'étudiant qui cherchent à meubler son
appartement à des gens qui peuvent être
effectivement un petit peu dans le
besoin et pour qui c'est un apport
précieux au quotidien pour augmenter son
pouvoir d'achat on peut avoir recours à
ces applications faire marcher la
concurrence au quotidien ou encore faire
appel à des spécialistes
dans le 8e arrondissement
nous avons rendez vous dans un point
budget conseil autrement dit un centre
d'accueil pour personnes en difficulté
budgétaire moi je pense que des régions
note globale oui mais sur un jeune par
exemple car un crédit s'étaient risque
sur les actions plus ciblées en france
il y en a 500 reconnu par l'état sur le
salaire en tant que tel nous on est pas
on n'a pas cette vocation à leur dire de
travailler plus ou de négocier leur
salaire encore plus par contre cela on
peut vraiment les aider c'est de baisser
le coût de leur vie le coût de leur vie
ça peut passer par des dépenses
contraintes ça peut passer par la cie
qualité par leur loyer par leur
appartement etc mais ça peut aussi
passer par des dépenses qu'ils ont et
dont ils rendent pas compte que
finalement c'est ce qui fait que étalée
sur plusieurs mois sur plusieurs années
c'est ce qui va faire que
potentiellement ils vont être dans des
situations très très difficile ce point
budget conseil vient de mettre en place
un questionnaire en ligne dans lequel
n'importe qui peut exposer sa situation
et demandé une expertise pour mieux
maîtriser ses dépenses et donc augmenter
son pouvoir d'achat c'est entre 150 et
200 demandes par mois qu'on va recevoir
sur le site c'est vraiment un volume
assez important beaucoup de situations
beaucoup de demandes est justement une
jeune femme vient de leur demander de
l'aide et à première vue elle ne serait
pas dans le besoin donc là il s'agit
d'une infirmière libérale donc elle a 31
ans elle a un enfant plutôt bien sa vie
puisqu'elle à 2900 euros par mois elle
peut pas trop d'impôts mais en revanche
apparemment elle a des difficultés à
joindre les deux bouts déjà falloir
qu'on a eus comprendre pourquoi quand on
lui pose certaines questions est-ce
qu'elles dépensent trop ce qu'il
consomme mal et non la plupart des
casses
oui
[Musique]
des courses au loyer en passant par la
déclaration fiscale votre compte est
passée au crible par le conseiller au
niveau du budget aujourd'hui vous dirais
que vous avez reste aviez de combien de
près aujourd'hui 40 % des français
déclarent se restreindre au quotidien et
30 % vont même jusqu à cumuler les
petits boulots pour s'en sortir
comment soulager le pouvoir d'achat les
salariés au sein des entreprises on en
parle avec vous bertrand dumazy bonjour
bonjour de visites chaque année à l'état
des pdg d'edenred alors avant de parler
de vos solutions elles sont nombreuses
pour pour favoriser pursuit est un
pouvoir d'achat déjà est ce qu'on est
bien loti quand on est un salarié et
donnerais tu sur fond quand une fois
d'inflation et 5% d'inflation à ce qu'on
perd du pouvoir d'achat quand on est
salarié d'eads un prête nom on gagne du
pouvoir d'achat et heureusement
puisqu'on ne les champions du monde de
l'argent fléchés et donc de la
redistribution davantage aux salariés et
donc vous avez vous parlé bon on parle
des nôtres mais on parle de 2 millions
de salariés dans le monde puisqu'on à 50
millions d'utilisateurs de nos solutions
et on est présent dans 46 pays sur vos
salariés sur les salariés donnerait bien
sûr mais je jeu puisque on fait ça
partout dans le monde d'abord on va
s'occuper de nos salariés donc est ce
qu'on est bien loti d'abord en france on
a été augmenté en moyenne de 3,2 pour
cent alors que pour les salariés de
l'ensemble du corps français on est
plutôt aux alentours de 2% avec une
inflation qui sera pris autour de 5%
alors on a encore du temps pour pour
pour faire d'autres choses mais on n'a
pas fait que ça deuxièmement évidemment
comme on est leader mondial du ticket
restaurant dans le monde le ticket
restaurant chez edenred est à son
maximum et il est cofinancé par
l'employeur c'est à dire un mois à
hauteur de 60 % ce qui est quasiment
unique en france puisqu'on est plutôt à
50/50 troisième mandat pousser à fond le
ticket cadeau kadéos leader également
mondiale produit edenred 250 euros pour
chaque collaborateur et puis comme nos
affaires tourne bien il y a de la
participation et d'intéressement qui
peuvent représenter jusqu'à un mois de
salaire sur l'année 2021 bon quand on
voit l'action edenred je regardais sur
sur cinq ans on a plus que doublé et
comme vos salariés peuvent participer à
cette création de valeur cette création
cet enrichissement de votre entreprise
est ce que vous seriez prêt pourquoi pas
allez soyons fous à distribuer des
actions gratuites au pur pour les
collaborateurs pour qu'ils soient
actionnaires alors on le fait déjà c'est
à dire que les réinventer l'eau chaude
mais donc on a des programmes d'actions
gratuites chaque année et qui concerne
en gros quatre cents personnes dans
l'entreprise sur d'un mille salariés
après chaque collaborateur est vite
c'est une
mais c'est déjà un bon début puisque 400
sur 10000 à 7 un ratio qui est assez
généreux et c'est bien normal et
deuxièmement c'est des programmes qui
ont lieu chaque année donc vous avez des
entreprises où c'est une fois tous les
trois ans et nous il ya des allocations
qui tombe chaque année ce qui fait du
pouvoir d'achat en plus ce qui fait du
pouvoir d'achat en plus bon edenred il
faut le rappeler ce sont des solutions
de paiement pour les salariés il faut
expliquer en quoi c'est un système
gagnant gagnant pour le salarié
l'employeur mais je vous l'expliqué très
bien c'est à dire que sur le ticket
resto une part est financé par le
salarié une part par l'employeur mais il
ya pas de cotisations pour le salarié
annie pour l'employeur qui se battait
pas d'impôts non plus désocialisés
défiscalisées je me disais mais c'est
gagnant gagnant mais pour l'état s'est
permis puisque des cotisations à moi et
de l'impôt en moins bien dire qu'elle
aille à la tva qui rentre ça alors ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que tous les
calculs qui ont été fait soit par les
économistes keynésiens soit par les
économistes libéraux on arrivait à
quelque chose qui est unique c'est à
dire que les deux convergent sur le même
constat en disant quand l'euro quand
l'état met un euro en investissement de
défiscalisation sur du ticket restaurant
il en récupère un euro 60 une autre
manière de le dire ce système est aussi
gagnant pour l'état qui en gros gagne à
900 millions d'euros par an ça lui coûte
un milliard quatre et il en tire 2
milliards 3 donc c'est gagnant gagnant
gagnant c'est gagnant gagnant gagnant
gagnant puisque les restaurateurs ont dû
volumes supplémentaires en france et
environ 4 milliards 2,7 milliards de
volume qui va en fait directement chez
les restaurateurs le salarié c'est du
pouvoir d'achat l'employeur c'est de la
rétention est une adaptation nouveau
mode en fait de consommation pas
uniquement la cantine mais avec le
télétravail la cantine et du ticket
restaurant et ses gagnants également
pour l'état en fait je trouve que c'est
vraiment le symbole
du dialogue social à la française qui
fonctionne c'est à dire que vous avez
ces quatre parties prenantes qui se
mettent d'accord sur des règles un peu
contraignantes pour chacun mais en
acceptant ces règles et on joue en jeu
chacun gagne et on est capable de
l'exporter dans 45 pays dans le monde il
faudra augmenter selon vous bertrand
dumazy la valeur faciale du tiers est
stocké de 11,12 euros c'est 5 millions
d'euros environ et quelques il faudrait
la
on ne peut imaginer passer à 15 euros ça
ferait vos affaires évidemment mais ça
serait bon aussi pour le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés c'est le thème de
l'émission alors oui je pense que c'est
une mesure essentielle pour le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord la dépense moyenne pour
déjeuner aujourd'hui et aux alentours de
15 euros or un seul ticket par jour est
de l'ordre de 11 euros et pourquoi parce
qu en fait l'augmentation annuelle a été
très faible année après année alors que
l'enrôlement le surcoût des denrées
alimentaires est bien supérieur à ce que
l'évolution du ticket restaurant a rendu
c'est une première chose la deuxième
c'est que ce système fonctionne c'est à
dire que quand on a permis aux français
pendant le coc vie de dépenser plus de
manière journalière pas sur le mois mais
de manière journalière en faisant passer
plafond de 19 à 38 euros par jour les
français ont immédiatement c'est à dire
le lendemain dépenses et non plus 14
euros en moyenne mais 21 euros donc on
sait que ça fonctionne troisièmement ses
co financés par l'employeur et l'employé
rolande burger a réalisé une étude il ya
quelques semaines en demandant aux
employés est ce que vous aimeriez mettre
plus d'argent dans ticket restaurant 70
% ont dit oui on est prêt à mettre plus
parce qu'on a besoin de plus à l'arrivée
tickets restants y aussi le ticket
mobilité pour pour payer son plein
d'essence et là pour le coup le salarié
cinéma compris ne met rien tout est pris
en charge par l'employeur à quelle
hauteur en france la loi mobilité permet
à un employeur de financer jusqu'à 600
euros au travers d'un ticket mobilité
pour la mobilité de ses collaborateurs
mobilité qui a augmenté et dont le coût
a augmenté il a augmenté d'à peu près 15
% depuis 12 mois ça veut dire que pour
se déplacer sur son lieu de travail pour
des collaborateurs français c'est de
plus en plus cher une des raisons étant
le prix de l'essence à un employé peut
finir un employeur peut financer jusqu'à
600 euros pour la mobilité de ses
salariés sa cellule pour d'achat c'est
du pouvoir d'achat directement
distribuée de l'employeur à l'employé
sans cotisation et sans cotisations
sociales est ce que le risque c'est pas
que tous ces chèques cadeaux ces tickets
se substituent à des hausses de salaires
c'est une question qui se pose
cette question est bien légitime je ne
le crois pas c'est à dire que ces sujets
sont des sujets complémentaires et
d'ailleurs moi même étrange chefs
d'entreprise et et en chef d'entreprise
depuis longtemps j'ai participé aux
négociations salariales annuelles donc
je peux en parler
en connaissance de cause quand vous
négociez avec vos partenaires sociaux
vous commencez toujours par
l'augmentation annuelle de salaire et
comment elles s'appliquent en fonction
des différentes catégories et en
fonction de la santé de l'entreprise
c'est toujours ça et il existe toujours
un écart entre le désir bien légitime
des partenaires sociaux mais aussi la
capacité légitimes de l'entreprise à
remplir ses désirs et il existe toujours
un écart et la manière de faire la
soudure entre les deux c'est de rajouter
ces systèmes en disant ok vous voulez 4%
mais on peut faire 3-2 mais on va faire
un effort sur les tickets restaurant
c'est à dire on va rajouter un euro et
puis on n'a pas encore deux tickets
télétravail ça s'installe allez on le
met en place et donc vous êtes capable
en panachant l'ensemble de ces mesures
de trouver un juste équilibre entre le
désir des représentants du personnel
encore une fois des désirs bien légitime
et les capacités financières de
l'entreprise et au final combien de
salariés bénéficient à la fois ticket
mobilité tickets resto titre télétravail
alors en france vous répondu voyance en
france pour les pauvres pour les
produits edenred ça représente à peu
près 3 millions de personnes premier
salarié 3 millions de salariés on se dit
qu'à la marge on se dit qu'à bourg soit
15 millions de salariés dont il y en a
un peu plus de 20 milliards $ y ait en
france et là on parle des salariés du
privé parce que vous avez toute la
fonction publique qui échappe encore à
ces avantages qui sont redonné donc on a
un travail réel le frein pour encore une
fois les 15 millions de salariés qui ne
ment pas et donc tout ça dans toutes les
entreprises qui n'ont pas encore passé
le pain alors je pense qu'il faut le
prendre produit par produit par exemple
si vous prenez le ticket restaurant en
france vous avez une part de marché du
ticket du titre restaurant au sens
générique du terme de l'ordre de 26%
vous avez encore un quart des salariés
français qui vont à la cantine vous avez
un quart des salariés français qui
ramène leur gamelle au travail et vous
avez un quart des salariés qui rentre à
la maison pour déjeuner je pense que
pour la gamelle et pour la cantine cette
proportion on est amené à baisser et à
devenir adeptes en fait du titre
restaurant qui est globalement moins
cher à gérer pour l'entreprise et avec
un niveau de satisfaction qui est bien
supérieure pour le pot pour l'employé
donc il faut prendre en fait comment
dire programme par programme pour le
télétravail on répond se rappelle qu'en
france on a à peu près 20% des salariés
français qui ont un accès au télétravail
parce que vous avez des métiers qui ne
permettent pas de télétravailler est
donc déjà on travaille sur une base un
peu plus petit et puis c'est des
programmes où il faut faire preuve de
pédagogie c'est à dire il faut les
expliquer il faut il faut être patient
il faut trouver les budgets qui vont
bien et donc ça va se construire dans le
temps on finit là dessus juste une
petite question nos voisins belges ont
des éco chèques est-ce que c'est à
regarder parce qu'on se dit que ça
pourrait permettre de flécher les
dépenses vers des produits bio vers des
produits locaux oui alors c'est un
programme qui a utilisé par 1 millions
7,2 belge je rappelle qu'en belgique
vous avez 12 millions d'habitants et
donc vous avez un million 7 de salariés
belges qui aura accès à un éco chèques
c'est à dire de l'argent fléché qui ne
peut être utilisé que pour acheter des
écoproduits chez des échos marchands
c'est-à-dire des produits dits
écologique ou plus responsable
derrière ça il ya une volonté
pédagogique de l'état belge de dire il
ya beaucoup de gens qui achètent des
produits non écologique parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais eu la chance de le faire
parce que le proverbe d'achat est un peu
limité ça coûte un petit peu plus cher
donc on va les aider à faire un premier
pas et quand ils auront fait ce premier
pas alors la chose va prendre c'est un
million 7 de salariés en belgique
aujourd'hui si vous faites une règle de
trois pour la france ce serait 10
millions de salariés en france si on
avait le même taux de pénétration qu'en
belgique voilà c'est à dire du potentiel
il ya du potentiel de redistribution du
pouvoir d'achat les outils existent
il s'agit maintenant de les comprendre
et de les mettre en place de manière
digitale allez merci beaucoup bertrand
dumazy le pdg d'edenred merci beaucoup
merci la ville pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui magazine à
voir ou revoir sur public sénat et du
replay bien sûr sur publicsenat.fr
rendez vous dans deux semaines pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien des god et ds
[Musique]